[Music]
foreign
the lessons Uganda learned from the
coronavirus pandemic are proving helpful
in its approach to the current Ebola
outbreak
for now there's still no vaccine against
the virus species but the East African
nation's medical professionals are
better prepared
welcome to the covid-19 special
how is the Ebola virus different from
covid-19
we talked to virologist Wolfgang priza
and what's the difference between a
virus strain and a virus variant
but we start the show in Germany where
the latest covid-19 variants are causing
a fresh spike in infection rates
an adapted vaccine targeting Omicron is
now available and one doctor in Berlin
is being kept very busy
[Music]
here in Berlin's noikon District
patients have come to the doctor to get
a booster shot since the start of the
pandemic they've been flocking to GP
Sevilla katzenstein's practice to get
tested and vaccinated
foreign
in the early days the doctor's office
was overrun
but now things have calmed down
we make a point of reaching out to
patients who are vulnerable and also
testing to see if someone has a
pre-existing condition then we offer
them Pax lovid elderly patients too but
it's a completely different situation
compared to last winter at least in my
practice
Dr katzenstein has vaccinated about 20
000 people in her practice at the moment
the elderly and people with underlying
conditions are Keen to get boosters and
flu shots but she believes that as
winter approaches the situation calls
first and foremost for the right
information
I mentioned you into people who are
vulnerable need to protect themselves I
wear a mask at work to protect my
patients and my staff I'm not sure if
Government efforts are working I'm not
sure it helps to reintroduce compulsory
mask measures and Dolls every winter
it makes sense in the health sector in
hospitals and doctors and physiotherapy
practices but I don't think the
authorities should dictate our every
move
in Germany's inner cities most public
health and safety measures have been
dropped but authorities are mulling a
reintroduction of restrictions such as
mandatory masks indoors most people are
taking a relaxed approach and more or
less stick to the current rules
I'm not worried these days I just keep
to the rules try to protect myself it's
been I'm vaccinated
I used to be really worried about going
shopping
but now I feel pretty safe and I trust
that people are protecting themselves
and sticking to the rules
[Music]
I'm kind of worried we're not out of the
woods yet it's been two years this is
the third winter and it seems like we
haven't learned anything
politicians are
safety measures to ensure the Health
Care System doesn't get overwhelmed the
number of covet patients in icus is
currently stable
but as the third coveted winter
approaches Hospital staff are feeling
the strain and they're struggling with
high infection rates
in the last few weeks infection rates
have gone up among the general public
and among doctors and nurses
this puts additional pressure on the
system we've had to reduce the number of
available beds because so many are off
sick both in the short term and the long
term
Oxford
higher energy costs are putting
hospitals under further pressure making
it all the more important to avoid
another coveted wave this winter
patients admitted with Omicron tend to
have mild cases and are treated on
normal wards
but staff shortages mean that some
hospitals are already postponing
non-emergency surgeries
we have to keep up with Emergency
Operations and emergency care
we have a duty to do so and we're doing
that
we're putting off certain procedures
well so long as it's safe to do so for
the patients
the German Health Care system is
understaffed overstretched and in urgent
need of reform
this applies to clinics as well as
doctors offices
sabila kotzenstein would like to see
some big changes
don't make life harder for healthcare
workers than it needs to be
there's too much bureaucracy and the
system is too hierarchical
it's too much jobs in healthcare need to
be made more attractive if people are
going to do them
Rising infection rates are just one of
many challenges facing Germany's Health
Care system this fall
[Music]
in the northern hemisphere the third
covert winter is approaching
take a look back at how the global
pandemic unfolded
the first year of the pandemic was about
unprecedented changes streets emptied
more or less overnight countries all
over the world closed borders and locked
down
masking up became compulsory there were
no vaccines and because Health Care
Professionals had little experience with
the disease catching it was a terrifying
proposition
has the first vaccines were rolled out
at the end of that first pandemic year
around 90 million cases of covid-19 had
been reported worldwide since then over
seven times that number of people have
tested positive for the disease and
experts estimate there have been many
many more unconfirmed cases
at the peak of the Omicron variant surge
last January the highest number of cases
in the pandemic so far over 20 million
people worldwide were testing positive
for the disease every week
throughout the pandemic deaths worldwide
unsurprisingly have reflected infection
worldwide a series of waves struck the
planet though different countries
suffered differently at different times
a retrospective reveals at least one
detectable pattern it was a simple and
devastating equation when the number of
cases Rose and fell in a new wave the
number of deaths followed a couple of
weeks later
the deadliest wave so far peaked in
early 2021 when in one terrible week
over a hundred thousand people died
worldwide but the equation has changed
somewhat since the massive Omicron wave
early this year large numbers of people
are still getting sick but on average
fewer are dying
the changing relationship between case
rates and death tolls is at least in
part due to another Factor widespread
vaccination
so far over 12 and a half billion doses
of vaccines have gone into arms all over
the world significant percentages of
populations in the Americas Europe and
Asia are now fully vaccinated though
there's still a lot to do in Africa
the biggest vaccination Drive in history
is not all on its own but enough to stop
the continued spread of covet 19.
but coupled with the immunity induced in
many people through wide scale exposure
experts say it's brought the day when we
declare the pandemic at an end a lot
nearer and save tens of millions of
lives
do you have any questions about covid-19
are science correspondent Derek Williams
is always up to date with the latest
findings and is here to answer them to
send your questions to covert producer
dw.com
[Music]
this week he answers the question what's
the difference between a strain and a
variant
this is one of those questions that I
get asked pretty frequently because for
the general public the term strain and
variant are often seen as synonyms and
and even some experts seem to sometimes
use them interchangeably so
let's start with some background all
viruses evolve over time which means
their genetic code changes during
replication as mutations occur in source
code V2 those mutations happen fairly
frequently compared to some other
viruses we call these mutated viruses
variants because they're different
genetically and and sometimes also
structurally
from their ancestors but but those
changes and this is important they don't
necessarily cause a variant to behave in
really new ways when those genetic
changes lead to new properties in a
virus however like it begins infecting
cells differently or it becomes much
much more transmissible then that's when
many experts begin talking about new
viral strains instead of areas so
strains are always variants but but
variants aren't always considered
strains unfortunately though there's
this kind of Muddy place in the middle
which is that naming viruses strains or
variants basically boils down to how
differently they behave compared to
their ancestors a subjective judgment
maybe it's easiest to take an example
from the macro world to explain it
though it's just a rough approximation
let's look for a second at dogs
different breeds can be really really
different in terms of their size and
their shape and the color of their fur
and and their temperament but they all
have something that I would like to call
intrinsically doggy they're all
variations on a common dogginess and if
dog breeds were viruses then we would
call them variants of dogs
now let's compare dogs to their close
evolutionary relatives wolves now here
the behaviors and characteristics really
clearly delineate one canine from the
other
wolfness and dogginess are so different
that if the two work irises we call them
different strains they're clearly
related
but they not only look different they
behave really differently too
um it's not a perfect metaphor maybe but
maybe a useful one
[Music]
the Sudan Ebola virus has been spreading
rapidly in Uganda in the last few weeks
there are still no approved vaccines
against this particular virus species
but thanks to experience gained during
the covid-19 pandemic the process of
identifying and isolating cases is now
more efficient than in previous
outbreaks
our reporter Julius mogambua visited the
village of maduru where the virus first
surfaced
[Music]
a grieving father and husband Maliko
simpawo has lost a son and his wife to
Ebola
health workers are closely monitoring
his family
they said that we must be under
surveillance for at least 21 days and I
often check our temperatures
that period has since passed
Uganda says that its Health Care system
is prepared to cope with Ebola
Central uganda's mobende Hospital
reported the first confirmed case of
Ebola at the end of September
doctors say that systems set up to fight
covid-19 can also be applied to Ebola
in the country
's population at that time the training
of health workers
the immigration of communities was
extensively experience during the time
of covet
which kind of experience has been drawn
over to this world bowler you have seen
that the response this time of Partners
and by the government is much much
faster
when covid-19 broke out Uganda formed a
special task force to advise the
government that emergency team has now
been redeployed to fight Ebola
but we have the same incident commander
who was heading covet is the one heading
Ebola with a scientific advisory
committee and part of that that
committee we have a steering committee
we have lab pillar we have case
management Peter we have Severance
pillar we have all these pillars and our
emergence response so these are helping
and they are the ones those who use for
covet now are being used for Ebola
before covid-19
Uganda had only one laboratory that
analyzed viruses
the government felt compelled to obtain
more diagnostic equipment to deal with
covet 19.
now the laboratory examines Ebola
samples on site
it used to take longer even days weeks
either that was a problem before you
intervene but now quickly we have the
labs you can easily quickly get the
results and you intervene for our test
takes about five hours the moment the
sample arrives in the lab takes five
hours but because we need to confirm
every sample that is positive we confirm
it and it may take 12 10 to 12 hours to
finally release the results
the people of Uganda also appear to be
more responsive
since the covid-19 pandemic Uganda began
local production of medical Essentials
like protective gear to support Health
Care
measures such as hand washing are also
widespread in the fight against Ebola
I don't
shake hands I don't hug
and I keep washing my keeping it
specifically
like washing hands washing the body
the measure of prevention
it is almost the same
during Kobe
we were asked to put on mask
that's why even when I'm communicating I
have my own mask
some challenges that arose during the
covid-19 pandemic remain during the
Ebola outbreak for instance many
Frontline health workers still feel
underpaid
Ministry of Health has not provided a
clear compensation plan for the health
workers who are dedicated and risking
their lives at the front line
in this tough battle against Ebola
hemorrhagic uh virus
a disease with a high fertility rate we
remember we lost over 64. not workers
during covet 19. they were never
compensated
the first Ebola case was reported on
September 20th in Maduro within weeks
the virus spread to a 200 kilometer
Radiance of the village
even so the Ugandan government is
confident that it can stop Ebola from
spreading further even without imposing
travel restrictions
travel restrictions hit uganda's economy
hard that's why the country's government
is hoping to avoid A Renewed ban on
non-essential travel at all cost
so far it looks like such drastic
measures won't be necessary
Ebola might be deadlier than covert but
it appears to be less infectious
[Music]
it hasn't ever spread around the world
like covid-19 did
DW reporter Adrian Krish finds out from
South African virologist Wolfgang prizo
How concerned are you about the
situation in Uganda at the moment
difficult to tell
these outbreaks they start slowly and
um then you know one one has to really
watch what what's happening in which
direction they are moving
um what we hear currently is that even
Uganda which is a country with a lot of
experience that has done very well in
the past with outbreaks of of this kind
is sort of struggling to contain it so
hopefully we'll see the the bending of
of the curve which so far is is
increasing with stricter measures having
been implemented now but yeah I'm I'm a
bit holding my breath and and so yeah
we'll I think the next few weeks will
tell us how how big this is going to get
can you explain us a little bit what
ebola does in the body so Ebola is is
one of the so-called hemorrhagic fevers
so the it manifests with massive
bleeding often after little injuries and
injection for example but also from from
the the natural
cases and and that happens because the
virus interferes with the liver that
produces the clotting factors to to help
our blood clot but also the cells lining
the vessels get damaged by the viral
infection and then the vessels leak out
blood and the the treacherous thing is
that this blood is very infectious so
people carry a lot of virus in their
blood and therefore and this is how
transmission usually happens that you
know bleeding starts and then others
rush to help and in the process infect
themselves if you compare this to South
scope SAS cov2 is really a respiratory
tract infection we know it also has
effects on amongst others the clotting
system in a different way it actually
leads to more rather than less clotting
but primarily it's an Affliction of the
respiratory tract starting in the in the
upper respiratory tract that's basically
in the back of your nose and throat and
in severe cases obviously also going all
the way down to affect the lung um and
and that is is you know it's of course
it's it's much less deadly than Ebola a
mortality rate is a lot less than than
that
um but the treacherous thing is that you
can have uh infection with a SARS Kobe
too with the coronavirus without showing
any signs of illness so you can feel
perfectly well but you are infected and
maybe passing it on let's briefly talk
about transmission of the disease
comparing Ebola to sarskovitz too maybe
to just make clear once again it is much
more difficult right to transmit ebullah
from one human being to another than
saskova II yes that's absolutely right
so sitting next to somebody
um would not transmit the infection but
it would of course with with the
coronavirus
um so for Ebola you really have to be
exposed to the body fluids of the
patient thank you bro better
in Colombia one teacher went well beyond
the Call of Duty to bring books to
Children during the pandemic
[Music]
Luis Soriano took a mobile library to
remote corners of the country
traveling by Donkey
riding his donkey Alpha Luis Soriano is
on his way to today's appointment at the
Divino Nino Elementary School in the
department of Magdalena in Colombia
the teacher has loaded his faithful
companion with books from his Library
he believes that delivering books to
school children is an effective way of
fighting social inequality
rural education in Colombia is in bad
shape it needs more support from the
state for teachers
biblioborough was born out of sheer
necessity
teachers lack resources especially here
in the department of Magdalena which is
one of the most disadvantaged in the
country
we need to combat ignorance to reading
what is going to help the future
population is reading
Luis Soriano continued to bring his
books to the region even during the
pandemic defying the restrictions on
movement that were put in place to help
stop the spread of kovid
he refused to put his mission on hold
personal around personally it was a
challenge because my family thought I
was putting myself at risk at one point
I was detained by the police because I
shouldn't have been on the street but
knowing the loneliness that exists in
the countryside I felt that moral duty
to keep being able to deliver his books
and avoid spreading covert he used old
farmyard cages as mailboxes he called
his plan catch a read
when we started catcher read the kids
guarded the cages and waited impatiently
for me to come by
I told them that they could only take
the book out of the cage after an hour
but they couldn't wait that long they
went and got it after only five minutes
but thank God nothing happened and I'm
sure they were always hoping to actually
meet again
in Colombia's remote municipalities
books are simply too expensive for
people to buy
the few books that reached Sophia's
hands have all been brought here by Luis
Soriano
another of his regulars is Luis Fernando
he's the first in his family to learn to
read he asked for books with pictures so
that his parents could follow what he
was reading
no matter how sad you are he always
makes you smile with his books
he always motivated us to read
the kids have started reading now too
whenever he comes to our house we have
something to read
[Music]
for teachers in the region the
biblioborough visits both during and
after the pandemic have been the best
way to ensure their students stay
motivated and keep discovering new books
we read a book it motivates us to read a
new one
but if we just have the same ones as
last year the kids already know them
so what Ben
we don't even have internet here
Luis Soriano has also built a public
library for the school children and
their neighbors
the biblioborough goes to places that
tend to be neglected where people are
forgotten because these are people who
deserve respect who need to be helped
and whose imaginations need to be
nurtured
imagination
Luis Soriano is almost like a character
out of a Gabrielle Garcia Marquez novel
a man who takes books to remote corners
of Colombia by Donkey and not even a
pandemic can stop him
that was this week's covid-19 special
until next time goodbye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]